[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir sehen uns hier in einsteiger im
truppenübungsplatz ein stärkt das ist
der grösste übungsplatz des
österreichischen bundesheeres und das
partner am 14
und hier mit circa 200 man einerseits an
kampfpanzer selbst aber natürlich auch
die versorgung und die instandsetzung
und kehren dieser zwei wochen dieser
nächster woche ist die schule und das
training unserer milizsoldaten
das spannende an dieser übung ist das
zusammenführen von milizsoldaten mit
berufs kader mit rund verdienen
wir haben neben den 500 soldaten vom piz
kraft getreten es läuft haben wir auch
42 grundwehrdiener vor allem das
einrichtungs termins oktober 20 18 für
ihre letzten wochen des bundesdienstes
verbringen und das ganze gut unterstützt
ausgebildet im rahmen und 60 von einer
berufssoldaten ebenfalls beginnen von
cabral
sie intonierten partei und kommunen wir
freuen uns sehr auf die zusammenarbeit
mit der miliz mit dem grundwort ihnen
nur ganz viele verschiedene fähigkeiten
zusammenlaufen und insgesamt das
ergebnis sicher ein gutes wird
ziel und zweck der übung ist es unsere
milizsoldaten hauptwaffensysteme leopard
2 oder 4 wieder fit zu machen und dann
mit dieser basis fitness im gefecht
technische ausschnitte zu gehen um hier
die militärische landesverteidigung zu
der höhepunkt werden nächste woche zwei
company kampf lage sein die auch durch
unsere stadtchef besucht werden